IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Hi, everyone.
I'm Ibrahim Ulukaya from
YouTube API Developer
Relations Team.
And today we are going to talk
about a new API and set of
functionalities called YouTube
Live Streaming API.
Joining me today, Satyajeet
Salgar, who is the product
manager of YouTube Live & Sports
and Derek Tan, who is
the [? technique ?] for the
Live Streaming API.
Thanks so much for joining
me today, guys.
DEREK TAN: Thank you.
SATYAJEET SALGAR:
Thanks, Ibrahim.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: So before going
any further, Satyajeet,
please tell us about
the new YouTube
live streaming platform.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Sure, we're
really excited about the live
platform that we've built at
YouTube and the kind of
experiences it's enabled.
Over the last few months,
we've seen an incredible
number of events from our
content partners.
Everything from the Red Bull
Stratos jump, which had over 8
million concurrent viewers, to
the election of the Pope, to
the last US presidential
elections.
And just a number of e-sports
tournaments, gaming events,
news events, and
sports events.
The live engineering team at
YouTube does an incredible job
with our platform.
We have an incredible stream
quality and features like
transcoding in the cloud.
So you only need to send us one
stream and we transcode it
to all the different
device formats
and resolutions required.
Things like adaptive bit rates,
we figure out the right
stream quality to send to the
user based on their bandwidth.
DVR, so users can skip
back and forth.
And we make it really easy to do
things like insert slates,
insert ad cue points.
We're really excited about the
kind of experiences this
platform will enable for
our YouTube creators.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: OK, great.
Derek, maybe after this talk,
the main question in
everyone's mind, what's the
Live Streaming API?
What are the functionalities
coming with this API?
DEREK TAN: Yeah, the YouTube
Live Streaming API is a set of
API methods that allow you to
create, update, and manage
your live events.
It currently consists of three
major APIs, live broadcast,
live stream, and live
cue points.
Live broadcast and live stream
are built upon the
YouTube Data API.
Live cue point is built upon
the YouTube Partner API.
And by using this free API,
you are able to schedule a
live event, configure the
stream, start and stop the
live event, enable DVR, enable
recording, and monetize it by
adding the ad cue point.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: OK.
In addition to these core
features, actually, what is
the target developer audience
for this API?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Sure.
The YouTube live streaming is
enabled for a set of YouTube
content partners.
We expect the Live API to make
it much easier for them to
create and manage their
own events.
In addition, we expect some of
the most interesting uses of
this API to come from developers
that are building
tools and apps for these
partners, either new products
or integrating it into
existing products.
I believe you're going to demo
one such product later today.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah.
That will be rad, actually.
Actually, we just talked about
the core features.
And from the developer's
documents, I just saw that
this API interacts with the
Data API and the Content
Partner API.
Derek, can you explain a
little bit about this
interaction and the philosophy
behind it?
DEREK TAN: Yeah, sure.
One philosophy of the new API
is to make it very easy to
understand and simple to use.
In the old API, we duplicate
some functionality with the
Data API and YouTube API.
In the new design, we just make
it very specific to the
Live API, and moved the regular
video management and
functionality to Data
API and Partner API.
For example, if you want to
monetize your stream, monetize
your video, you just call the
Partner API to claim the video
content and then call the Live
Cue Point API to add cue point
in real time.
And another example is that if
you want to get the regular
video metadata, for example,
on how many users like your
video, just call the Data API.
And obviously, if you want to
get the broadcast metadata,
for example, the life cycle
status or broadcast stream
status, just call
the Live API.
And if you see the Live API
spec, you should see that the
new API request and response is
much shorter and clearer.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Thanks, Derek,
for clearing this up.
And I just also want to say at
this point that actually the
Live Streaming API, the
library actually comes
on this Data API.
And maybe if you're wondering
where is the Live Streaming
API in your dev console, once
you enable the Data API, the
live streaming capabilities
will also be enabled.
Being said that, actually
are there any new scopes
introduced with this new API?
Or are they using the same
scopes that the YouTube Data
API is using?
DEREK TAN: Yes.
Live Broadcast and Live Stream
API are based on the
YouTube Data API.
So they share the same OAuth2
scope, which are YouTube doc
read only and YouTube.
Live Cue Point API is a part
of the Partner API.
It uses YouTube partner
as OAuth2 scope.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: OK, I
think that's great.
Thanks for joining me, guys.
And I think that's a great
time to start seeing some
demos and few examples from
more early integrators.
So maybe a good example to start
is the create broadcast
example I created, which
actually does OAuth2
authorization that creates a
broadcast and that creates a
stream and then binds them
together so that you have
already a stream.
You have already scheduled
a broadcast that
you can just stream.
Let's go over the example.
So for this example, we use the
OAuth2 authorization, as I
described, going through
the Google
authorization code flow.
And once the user actually
authorizes us to use their
credentials, then what we do
is we create our YouTube
object and create a broadcast
with a title, the scheduled
start time, scheduled
end time.
And so I think it's private.
Status to private.
We first create an insert
request, execute the request,
get a response as a
broadcast object.
So we just print out all the
broadcast object's properties.
And then we create a stream
in a similar way.
We get the title, we set
the broadcast title.
Then we set the CDN format.
The content distributed
format is 1080p.
And we set the ingestion
type as RTMP.
Then we create an
insert request.
But with the execution of the
insert request, we get a
response as a stream.
And we just print
out that one.
And then we create
a bind request.
And we actually execute the bind
request and then we'll be
ready to go.
So let's actually do this
and see how it works.
So we create a broadcast.
Let's say we create
a broadcast title
as broadcast 1.
We get the broadcast title,
start time, end time.
Let's create stream 2.
We get the stream.
Oh yes.
And there's one thing I actually
added into the
example that you also return the
ingestion address, which
you will be using while
you're streaming.
So once you create this stream,
you actually get an
ingestion address that
you will put
into your actual streamer.
And let's see in the--
actually in all sides, while we
refresh our all sides, you
see the broadcast is
already created.
And once we see in the
Channel Settings, we
also check the streams.
And in Streams, we
also see that our
stream is already created.
I think this is a good time
we can just check
all the other examples.
Our first example is from
Elgato Game Capture HD.
MALE SPEAKER: With Elgato Game
Capture HD, you can record
your PlayStation and Xbox game
play to a Mac or a PC and
share your clips with
your friends.
Now YouTube has made it
really easy to live
stream your game play.
Go live with the click
of a button.
[GUNFIRE]
GAME CHARACTER: If you need
me to move, just fire it.
[GUNFIRE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Let's see
another example from Capella
Systems' Cambria Live.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Cambria
Live is an [INAUDIBLE]
level software that encodes live
broadcasters in real time
and uploads them to popular
streaming service.
With YouTube Live Channel, you
can add account from Account
Manager, enter email and
password registered with
YouTube Live Channel.
Please note that you must be
certified contents partner in
order to stream to YouTube
Live Channel.
Once you enter email and
password, YouTube Live account
is added in the Account
Manager.
You can then select YouTube from
target and it will bring
up all channels registered
from your account.
Once specify channel, it
automatically inputs suggested
presets by YouTube for optimal
video quality.
You can simply start streaming
all the streams by clicking on
Start Streaming.
Even after it's started
streaming, you can change
video quality by clicking on
Show Other Band Settings.
You can modify frame size,
frame rate, video aspect
ratio, and also bit rate.
You can also preview streaming
preview page by clicking
Streaming Preview from the
encode settings, allowing you
to verify the stream looks OK.
Cambria Live comes with a very
powerful edit tool called
Cambria Live Edit.
We use with our file based
transcoding software called
Cambria File Convert.
User can create highlight clips
on the file during a
live event by simply setting in
and out points within the
Cambria Live Edit timeline.
This edit point data then
transfers to Cambria File
Convert, which can generate
highlight clips in multiple
video formats and also upload
the encoded files to FTP site
or YouTube VOD channel.
You can seek in and out points
at any point of the live event
and create multiple highlight
clips without
having any down time.
There is also an option to
immediately re-import the
segment back to live, without
sending it to
Cambria File Convert.
So while you're doing continuous
streaming, you can
re-stream highlights without
having any down time.
As you can see, Cambria Live is
a very unique and powerful
production tool that enables and
enhances professional live
streaming broadcast
production.
If you'd like to know more about
Cambria Live, please
visit our website at
www.capellasystems.net.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Well, that
was the demos, and I think
it's a great API.
And thanks for joining me, guys
today, for this hour.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Thank you.
DEREK TAN: Thanks
for having us.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Now I think you
guys are really excited.
And I hope you enjoy this API
and start using it right away.
Have a great day.